how rich are they?
on the internet says,
1 comma 4 billion.
yes,,
Total speed camera.
it says to be this,
the richest Cologne man.
yes,
maybe i actually am,
but they should.
we have seen the houses in Berlin,
for example,
several 100 million.
that is right.
yes, that is already true.
50 percent of the German half,
i.e.
the poorer half,
owns,
what do you think,
what percentage of total assets?
i know these statistics,
1 comma 4 percent.
yes,
Yeah, sure.
and if they get 1020 percent now,
what happens?
then they have 20 percent more consumption,
so it will be short bubble.
well,
they have little more security in life life.
if the accordingly
actually in this direction
would use,
then they are right.
do they?
i don't know,
but it sounds like this now,
as if people could not handle the money.
i'll make sure,
that certain things happen.
when the money is distributed.
will it be invested here,
here, will it be spent?
that can also be invested.
people just can't.
when they have nothing,
then they tell me who that is.
the Germans
are not a country
of personal responsibility.